[Music]
all right let's go to the phones let's
go to
joshua in portland oregon what's up
brother josh how are we doing man
i'm doing pretty good how are you dr
john i'm all right what's going on in
oregon
oh so i'm calling you today because
i am the other man and i'm
struggling on what to do and how to
progress forward here
what is the other backstory here but i
don't know how much time i have to
really tell you that everything is
going on up to this point so cut right
to the decisions i've made
cut right to the chase so you made bad
decisions and you're the quote-unquote
other guy i'm pretty sure i know what
that means
um yeah she's been married
uh she was married for about a year we
you know first started out as friends
turned into a relationship now it's
about you know nine months
or night four months ago uh after nine
months of being in a relationship
she's trying to know she's pregnant um
with your child she's pregnant
uh i doubt it's mine it's like
very low chance it's mine um timing
doesn't make any sense but at the same
time there's a possibility
and the guy the husband still doesn't
know about me
girl doesn't know about anything that's
going on um
so why why are you calling me man
because i feel like my moral accomplice
is all over which i've been wrong for so
long
that i'm trying to debate about how i
step out of this
and do i tell him do i confront him
um i just feel like my moral compass i
mean
making the wrong choice after wrong
choice how do i make it right
i'll ask you man how do you make it
right
i mean it's like i i have feelings for
her i love her and
i'm struggling on how to progress and
either phase out of this because i love
her
because i know it'll be best for a
family to be together hey how does this
end man
how does this end that her husband and
you and her go to go to dinner one night
and he's like you know what we're
married
but y'all y'all are more perfect than us
and so
my brother joshua i i am handing this
one off to you
i wish you all the best is that how that
ends
that's probably not how it's gonna end
yeah zero percent chance dude that won't
happen that way
it only ends in ashes in a disaster
and let's say she calls this her husband
and breaks it off and you all get
together
for the rest of your relationship every
time she takes a call you're going to be
wondering if there's another another guy
every time she gets an email and closes
her laptop as you walk in the room
you're going to wonder
i wonder if there's another another guy
yeah there's no way this ends right
and by the way you don't love her she is
a safe
uh person to get into a relationship
with
because she's anchored in and you can
just trapeze off the side of this thing
with all all the fun and excitement and
joy and you have no responsibility at
all
none well
i mean i'm trying to do the responsible
thing which is i mean even if it is my
kid i mean i want to raise it i want to
be with her and
i mean it's just listen to stepping out
joshua
the responsible thing is to walk away
if this happened if this happens to be
your kid which you told me earlier it
wasn't
if this happens to be your kid then yes
this whole thing got real real real
messy
right and you may have a single woman to
start dating because
if um her husband's a person a character
he's probably gonna high five her and be
gone
yeah cause she's having a baby by
somebody else
and god no you have don't go why would
you are you friends with her husband
no i'm not friends i've met him a few
times yeah
there's no reason to call him
i just feel like i've done so much
damage you know after
a walk away walk away
you're like a surgeon who is taking
somebody's organ out and they realize
they cut the wrong organ
and they realize oh gosh i've caused a
lot of damage i think the best thing to
do here is to keep cutting out other
organs
and just keep cutting and keep cutting
and keep cutting
at some point the smart thing for that
doctor to do is to stop
put the scalpel down
yeah and you know you know this
why did it take a phone call to a
stranger you know this man
because it's hard to hear it's hard to
walk you know i've
had i've struggled with uh finding
somebody you know that
matches me it's just i'm tired of being
alone
you're still completely alone man
that's the farce of this you're totally
completely alone
you are somebody else's chew toy on the
weekends
you are somebody else's excitement
you're a video game for somebody else
but they have their stable locked in
thing
you're completely alone joshua and
that's what breaks my heart for her
breaks my heart for you
yeah you know what i'm saying you're not
on a team right now
no no you're right you're right and
you're worth more than that
she's worth more than that her husband's
worth more than that this baby coming
into the world's worth more than that
so true you know what i mean am i crazy
i know no no you're not crazy you're not
crazy i mean bro you're totally alone
right now
it's hard to accept it's hard trust me i
know it sucks it's awful
it's hard but i'm not gonna lie to you
do you have friends that know this is
going on do you have like some
guy buddies that you sat down and talked
to about this
well i have got buddies but the problem
is i haven't
told him about it because i'm ashamed
yeah my shame has kept me
you know kept them in the dark and kept
me from saying the truth
will they hold you accountable they
would
yeah so here's the thing man you can do
what you want
i'm going to tell you right now i've
been around the block long enough to
know
this thing ends disaster
whatever fantasy you've come up with in
your head is not real
okay so if i'm you
i would probably talk to call my buddies
over tonight
and say we gotta have a talk
just so i'd have somebody with me when i
go ahead and make that other phone call
because you're not gonna see her again
you can make that phone call says i'm
down i'm done
if this baby when it's born is mine then
i will step back in
but until then i'm gonna do the thing of
uh the right thing i haven't been a
virtuous person
i've been a person without character
i've been sleeping with a married woman
i've been violating somebody else's
marriage i'm out
walk away that's it man or dude
rock on no no you're right you're right
i just need to
i see you hear from somebody that i
respected of amount of characters so
it's just
it's hard for me to confess it to
somebody i know i got that i got that
hey that's that's the first step here
and that's what i'm going to tell you to
do with your guy buddies so they'll be
there
with you and if your guy buddies are
like my guy buddies it's probably gonna
get physical
yeah they're gonna wrangle me they
should that's what you're that's what
that's what made a character do for one
another that's what men and women of
character do for one another man
yes you called and you asked um
the right thing is this is over before
the day's over and you've got some guys
in your life that are walking alongside
you
and not the ex i get that you're tired
of being alone there's a right way and a
wrong way to do that that's like saying
i'm tired of being broke i can go rob a
store
or i can start taking community college
classes and get three jobs
one of those are gonna result in money
at the end of the day one of those is
noble one of them is not
right and josh you know this man i
appreciate you trusting me with that
call
let me know do me a favor man i want you
to write me back and let me know how the
conversation goes or write me back and
say man i forget it dude i just decided
i'm gonna stick it out and see what
happens
let me know that too and i'll let the
listeners know because they're gonna be
interested in how this one plays itself
out but thank you so much for that call